可听风，
也就是我是两年多前，
然后开始看你的视频，
感觉对我的恋爱观婚姻观有很多正向的影响，
感觉从你这里还是学到了很多的，
然后我现在对我的感情状态也是比较满意，
但是我想跟您聊一点我职业上的事情，
只是说聊一聊，
就是以以您的社会经验给我提点意见，
对呀，
好，
我是今年的广东这边的一个985的博士毕业生，
我是属于硕过连读，
然后研毕业了一年，
就是也是属于那种延长毕业的那种，
在毕业前我自己对科研就是是那种生物医学领域的，
然后我自己对科研感觉也是没有太大信心了，
就比较受凑的那种，
然后我自己想的就是本来是想要考公考编，
但是就是我三月份的时候考编，
当时经验嘛，
但是那个没有太多时间准备，
因为在毕业的阶段嘛，
反正就是面试没面上，
但是你要等下一次考公啊，
或者考编又是可能半年以后的事情了，
所以我想说先找一份工作过渡一下，
然后我当时找了一家生物公司，
他是在我读国期间，
我是他们的客户，
然后看他们在网上有这个招聘，
我就去面老师，
他们只是招硕士，
然后工资大概就是1万左右一个月，
但是我去念的时候，
他们公司比较小，
然后他们就是没有直接就是那个公司的老板来念我，
他们有HR，
但是就是可能公司老板就比较重视，
他就是给我开了一个很高的工资，
我其实不需要。
这么多钱，
我其实我心里有点怵，
我不知道啊到底能不能干好，
然后就是在这个时候，
正好有一个老师给我推荐了一个博后的工作，
这个博后就他们说考宝要求比较低，
然后工资也特别高，
加上我有一些同学也在那里做国后，
他们给我的意见也是比较推荐，
所以我就去了，
然后我现在是已经在这个博后的这个单位来了一个多月了，
但是这就是因为他们的手续办的很慢，
我就一直没有入职，
然后我最近就是打算我想我入职了，
然后我又找回了之前那个公司，
他们还是不愿意接受我，
然后也是给到这边博后差不多的工资，
就是挺高的，
就是我就想问这两个问题，
第一个是我要不要不做这个博后了，
然后第二个问题是要不要去这个小公司，
因为这个公司就是他是属于那种做国外产品的进口产品的代理，
然后代理之后这这部分销售营收来支撑他们来做研发，
然后他现在想让我过去是做研发的，
就是我感觉不管是这个博后的这个地方，
还是这个公司这个地方，
他们其实看中的是我的出身，
其实他们对我个人的能力并不一定就有太大的了解，
我不确定我能不能干好，
就是我来这个博后这个单位工作了一个多月之后，
就其实没什么太多事情，
就是我不知道我要干什么，
他们也没有人能指导我，
感觉我这两年是出不了成果的，
我觉得到时候等我博后出战有没有成果，
到时候可能也不好找工作，
我还不如从。
现在开始就去规划我以后要怎么走，
就我早点去闯社会，
早点去社会上面吃苦，
早点接受社会的阻打，
我这几天就很纠结这个事情，
因为你自己啊，
能读到博士毕业，
虽然说你说延毕了一年，
但你依然能够顺利的毕业，
这就是你学习能力的一个证明，
你自己本身学习能力是有的，
其实现在你的人生选择是要回到你心目中的那个理想的自己是什么样子的，
我认为每一个不管是男孩儿还是女孩儿，
在从小长大的过程当中，
在心里给自己一定会有一个画像，
就是你心里面最想看到自己成为的那个样子，
是从你的只言片语里面我能够捕捉到的是可能你觉得自己没有办法成为一个科研人才，
那在科研这条路上的话，
你自己觉得你的能力可能就到头了，
如果再让你去做一个什么生物医学方面的突破性的工作，
你觉得你没有这个能力，
是这样吗？
是的，
所以我就觉得，
虽然博后的工资很高，
而且可能就是时间上非常的自由，
但是我觉得就是我感觉我在这做这个博后唯一的意义就是他能赚钱，
但是我还是不想，
可能我的要求也不高，
包括我现在的男朋友对我要求不高，
我对我男朋友，
我觉得我最大的问题要找到自己的成就感，
找到自己的价值感，
就是你给我1万或者给我2万，
可能差别对我来说不是非常大，
如你。
你自己啊，
因为自己是相对来说的话，
是比较了解自己一路在读博过程当中是幸福的，
快乐的，
有成就感的，
还是怎么怎么样的，
如果你自己觉得你自己不适合走科研这条道路，
并且你也不认为自己有能力在科研上做什么突破的话，
咱们大可不必去勉强自己，
我也觉得是，
所以我就是现在我可能这个星期我就打算和博后这个单位的领导就提出来，
我可能不入职了，
因为我本来也没有签合同，
那我下一条路就是说我是去这个小公司做研发呢，
因为那个老板还是挺看重我，
但是我我觉得我不一定能够满足他的期待，
进去之后还是说我，
我再找其他的工作，
还是或然后同时准备考红考编，
就是相当于在家待业嘛，
但是我是这么想的，
就是我现在因为现在生物医药行业直不好找工作，
就是有点韩工那种感觉，
我如果再找的话，
首先我可能也比较难进那种大公司，
然后或者说进那种普通的学校去当类似于什么讲师啊或者辅导员啊，
就是反正都竞争挺大的，
如果我真的考公考编，
我考上了之后，
我觉得我可能还是比较能考上，
但是我真的考上之后，
我真的就很喜欢那份工作嘛，
我觉得也不一定，
所以我就是想说，
要不要我还是先去啊社会上工作几年考不考遍，
其实我现在还很年轻，
之后还是会有机会，
你知道吗？
啊，
对于你的这个困惑是几乎所。
课的年轻人在面对怎么选择职业的时候都有的困惑，
这就是为什么我们在大学的时候，
大三就开始让啊学生去各个岗位去实习的一个真正的原因。
比如说像王菲姐，
我自己去法院也实习过啊，
律师事务所也实习过，
那我自己要去对比我更适合什么样的工作状态，
对比下来之后，
我自己更适合律师事务所的工作状态，
我不太适合那个体制内的那样的，
要开会呀，
有的时候要搞什么活动呀，
搞什么评比呀，
写什么报告呀，
各种数据，
各种框框，
各种条条，
都要把你规范成一个基本上没有什么创作力，
没有什么热情的这样一个人，
那我自己就分析了自己的性格，
我就不适合，
那对于你来说的话，
现在是属于一个你都应该去。
感受一下，
不管是通过实习也好，
通过入职也好，
比如说现在的这个社会上的这个公司的小公司，
他们肯定是经济为向导的，
等你进到这个公司的第一天，
你都在用自己的每一个细胞去感受，
感受你适不适合这样的氛围，
因为有的小公司他们虽然说你是博士毕业，
或许你进去了之后，
可能还要承担其他的工作，
没准还要去拉客户，
没准还要去陪领导吃饭，
这都讲不清楚的，
都需要你去真正的去工作，
去体验你自己，
最终才能得出一个自己最向往的生活状态，
包括你说要不要考公考研，
那就是你进入这家公司了之后，
你去感受了，
如果你觉得你不适合，
你说我不适合，
在这种商业的环境下啊，
我一个博士，
我商业的环境下，
我还有的时候作为乙方，
我还得按照甲方的要求去改很多的东西，
或者按照甲方的要求去说一些违心的话的时候，
我觉得我做不了这个工作啊，
甚至也做不了跟着老板出去，
呃，
跟谁谁谁谈判，
因为你老板他之所以花那么多钱来请你，
他看中的就是你的身份，
那么你的身份在这个公司就是资产，
他一定会带着这样的资产去谈项目，
去拉各种各样的业务，
这是不可避免的事情，
你自己要自己去感受，
在这个过程当中，
你喜不喜欢这个角色定位。
对吧，
你如果说不喜欢好，
那就踏踏实实的再去考公务员，
考公务员进去了之后，
其实你也得去感受一下，
也得去适应一下，
好的好的明白就是，
反正我感觉确实你不去那边，
你永远都不知道那边到底是个什么情况，
我就感觉路的是自己走出来的，
没错，
这就是我特别希望大家大三的时候就是各个单位都找去实习一下，
待个一个月两个月的，
这个对人生的选择就特别有帮助，
可以帮你排除很多错误的选项。
好的好的，
谢谢谢谢，
我给你，
谢谢啊，
不见啊，
我们每一个人都要分析一下自己的性格，
我记得有一次有一个妹妹的投稿，
说她学的是老师这个专业的，
她性格也比较内向，
但是她又个不想当老师，
她问龙飞姐说她可不可以去读法学这个专业，
其实读法学这个专业，
我认为我个人觉得真正能够在这个专业领域里面有一定建树的，
就是出得来的，
有名儿的，
能挣着大钱的，
他身上一定有一些特质，
比如这个人就是一个特别有正义感的人，
他真的可以为了别人的不公的待遇，
自己愿意真的是倾其所有的去帮助他解决这个问题的，
他如果身上有这股劲儿的话，
他可能也能出来，
比如他是一个性格非常社会化的人，
他能够跟各行各业的人打上交道，
他能够跟各种层级啊，
大老板啊什么的都能够这个共同的话题可聊，
那么这样的人或许他会成为一个案源特别丰富啊，
资源特别丰富的律师，
但如果说你本身的性格就是属于那种不太愿意跟人打交道，
比较内向，
如果是这样的性格的话，
我实话实说，
你想要在法律这条路上啊成功。
得到一个很好的结果，
成为一个有名的律师，
或者成为一个特别优秀的法官的话，
我感觉是比较困难的，
因为做我们这个工作，
其实他归根结底是在跟人发生链接，
跟人打交道，
这个大家认同吗？
我有的时候也分析，
像龙飞律师，
我自己在干律师这件事情上，
相对来说的话还是可以的，
咱也不是说干到那种特别优秀，
但就还可以，
还过得去，
我分析一下我自己啊，
就是给大家提供一个思路，
我分析了我自己去，
就是我是一个比较愿意琢磨人的这么一个人，
我不一定是喜欢跟人打交道，
但是我喜欢琢磨人，
我喜欢把人琢磨明白，
我有的时候甚至我会把自己抽离出来，
来琢磨我自己，
来观察我自己，
来分析我的喜怒哀乐，
分析我当时的愤怒、
嫉妒，
分析我的情绪，
分析我的动机，
我也愿意分析别人。
我觉得这个是我能把律师这个工作干好的一个很大的一个因素，
就是我真的很愿意琢磨人，
很有意思了。
这事儿就是很多姐妹说为什么跟龙飞律师聊天啊，
总觉得龙飞律师能够抓住重点，
能够抓住那个关键的点，
就是因为我这辈子就喜欢琢磨人，
我甚至有的时候喜欢琢磨人的那个阴暗面啊，
琢磨人坏的那方面啊，
琢磨人特别不堪的那方面，
我也喜欢琢磨，
就以前读书的时候就特别喜欢研究犯罪心理学。